the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi I'm Johnny Sigmund I'm one of the
instructors in 5:07 I teach with Joann
stubby and boat Don Fidelis you've
probably seen in earlier videos of this
type today we're going to talk about the
pentose phosphate pathway professionally
I'm a toxicologist the pentose phosphate
pathway is one that is very central to
the people who work in my field
specifically because the pentose
phosphate pathway provides us with one
of the reagents that we need in order to
be able to combat or counter the effects
of oxidative stress oxidative stress is
involved in many pathologies one of the
reasons that the pentose phosphate
pathway is challenging to teach is
because it's it's a pathway that
interacts very very closely with other
pathways for example glycolysis the
energy generating pathway and
gluconeogenesis a pathway by which in
some organs you're able to synthesize
glucose from non carbohydrate precursors
the fact that these tend to be so
closely related makes it difficult to
see the distinct features of the pentose
phosphate pathway so let me show you the
pentose phosphate pathway and how it
interacts with these other pathways
first of all let me start with the roles
of the pentose phosphate pathway as I
see it there are three the first is this
is the cells principal source of NADPH
which is our reductive cofactor it's
used for the synthesis of such things as
lipids and other carbohydrates and so on
so this is how the reducing equivalent
the source of electrons that we use in
order to be able to synthesize complex
molecules
the second major role of the pentose
phosphate pathway is that it's our
biosynthetic source of ribose we have to
make ribose for things like ATP we have
to make it for the nucleotides that are
in our nucleic acids this is where comes
from we're also going to see is that
when we eat foods that contain ribose
for example ATP and nucleotides this is
how they enter the mainstream of
metabolism so that we can utilize them
as raw material or energy material and
the third thing about the pathway is
that some of the intermediates you'll
see what we call this carbon scrambling
phase are critical for the synthesis of
certain biomolecules this is where the
aromatic residues come from in our
aromatic amino acids such as tyrosine so
the pentose phosphate pathway is very
important because it provides us with
our reducing equivalents it provides us
with a biosynthetic source of ribose for
nucleotides and it provides us with
building blocks for more complicated
molecules
because this pathway is associated with
biosynthesis in terms of its providing
reducing equivalents what we'll find is
that there are the pathway is very
highly expressed in tissues that make a
lot of lipid lipid is our bio
energetically most expensive bio
synthetic process requires a lot of
NADPH if the cell is dividing what it's
going to do is make membranes and that's
a lot of lipid biosynthesis this pathway
the pentose phosphate pathway not
surprisingly is upregulated when we have
to make a lot of membranes for example
in a cell is growing and that means for
example that this could be a target for
anti-cancer drugs in other words if you
wanted to find a pathway to block in
order to stop the provision of the
resources the reductive resources for
growth this would be one - that would be
looked at in fact is being looked at by
the modern pharmaceutical industry
over here toward the center of the of
the top panel is what's often considered
to be you know that a little bit
confusing but it's really actually quite
straightforward which is the fact that
this pathway can run in two modes I said
earlier that the pentose phosphate
pathway is an offshoot of other pathways
which makes it a little bit difficult
for some people to understand so in this
line right across here that I'm just
moving across that's going from glucose
to pyruvate as we go left to right and
that's a coarse glycolysis if we went
from pyruvate to glucose that is going
from right to left
that's gluconeogenesis so
gluconeogenesis for example might be a
situation in a diabetic for example I'm
a diabetic
and when I go to sleep at night I'm not
eating and my livers doing is it's
saying okay you haven't eaten for a
while your blood sugar is dropping and
my gluconeogenic pathways start to
manufacture it in my case unfortunately
too much from non carbohydrate
precursors they move the carbon from
right to left and put out a lot of
glucose into my blood that's you know
one of the bend that's one of the uses
of the gluconeogenic pathway similarly
if the doberman pinscher which has
become commonly seen in in the 507
course so far starts to chase me down
the street what I'm going to want to do
is I'm going to want to take and break
down my glucose as quickly as possible
to bring it toward pyruvate to get fast
ATP that I can use to power my muscles
to be able to run away so that's the
gluconeogenesis and the glycolysis
pathways now imagine that you've got a
railroad track and that you've got a
sidetrack off of it and that's what the
pentose phosphate pathway it is it is a
track that comes off of glycolysis or
gluconeogenesis stuff happens and then
you could re-enter the main stream of
the train line the interesting thing is
that you can basically go in either
direction at certain parts of this
pathway what this really means is where
we have common components in both
the pentose phosphate pathway and along
this main line of gluconeogenesis
glycolysis and the common components
we're going to see our first glucose
6-phosphate second fructose 6-phosphate
and third glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate or
gap so these are the common features of
all three pathways
okay so I'm going to give you a little
bit of an overview first and show you
how these side two track works now the
pathway can be run in the oxidative mode
exclusively and what we'll see is and
again the details will come in a few
minutes that this glucose 6-phosphate is
going to be oxidized in order to
generate a read in the edition of
courses when electrons are removed from
the substrate and they're going to be
put into an adp to form NADPH which is
our reductive cofactor so this is an
oxidative arm now one of the
consequences of this oxidation is going
to be we're going to be losing a carbon
from the six carbon glucose 6-phosphate
and we're going to be forming a pentose
specifically ribulose 5-phosphate it's
going to be easily interconverted with
other pentoses five carbon sugars and
then I want you to notice that from here
on everything is reversible in the
pathway loss of co2 typically is
irreversible
so this first arm the first oxidative
arm is irreversible so if we go from
glucose 6-phosphate to pentoses that's a
one-way street
the pentoses if we are in the process of
cell division these can be used to make
nucleotides this is how we make pentoses
for nucleic acids if we don't need the
pentoses then the carbon from the
pentoses will continue along the pathway
and we'll go into this complicated
carbon scrambling Network which you see
underlined with the squiggly line over
here in the in the center and the
scrambling will result in the pentoses
being restructured into fructose
6-phosphate glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
so the carbon can then continue along
the pathway so I can imagine the pathway
going like this a cell let's say it's in
a situation where it is growing and it
needs NADPH and it needs pentoses for
making nucleotides so it takes and it
gets up to the glucose 6-phosphate stead
and so rather than progressing in
glycolysis it takes as you'll see a
right-hand turn make the NADPH that's
going to be needed for making those
membranes of the new cell
getting pentoses which are going to
convert into nucleotides and if you
don't use all of the pentoses then what
you want to do is you don't want any
waste material so you go through the
carbons scrambling Network and the
remainder of the material will go back
as fructose 6 phosphate and
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate so that's
what we'll call the the full pentose
phosphate pathway with the oxidative and
the non oxidative portions distinctly
shown everything is oxidative up to the
pentoses generation and then it's non
oxidative from pentoses through the
fructose 6 phosphate and
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate
now let's in the in case be over here we
call it the purely non oxidative mode
let's say you're in a situation where
you're not growing but you do need for
example ATP and you need pentoses for
that that's where the back door comes in
we're going to be taking in this case
out of probably gluconeogenesis remember
gluconeogenesis is the flow of carbon
from right to left in this pathway so it
could be amino acids and things from the
tricarboxylic acid or TCA cycle are
flowing carbon in this direction and it
goes up into the gluconeogenic pathway
and then the molecule repositories fill
up for glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate and
fructose 6-phosphate if I were to block
gluconeogenesis right here then carbon
would flow in this direction would go
through the back door of the pathway the
carbon scrambling phase would result
ultimately in pentoses so this would be
a biosynthetic route to pentoses again
that's a situation in which we do not
need NADPH perhaps we just need pentoses
okay so now let me get into the details
in the center of this piece of paper
what you'll see is the stoichiometry of
the pathway in most of 507 so far we
have seen that we work with a single
molecule of glucose working its way to
two molecules of pyruvate and so on here
the stoichiometry works up best or it's
easiest to teach and to appreciate if
you start with three molecules of
glucose and we'll see why in a few
minutes okay so what we'll do is I'm
going to do is take three molecules of
glucose 6-phosphate now looking up in
the top here so this is glucose to
glucose-6-phosphate this is the entry
portion right here with glue at glucose
6-phosphate into the oxidative arm of
the pathway so that's 18 carbons three
times 618 we're going to lose three co2
s that's going to leave us 15 carbons
left and those 15 carpets are going to
be distributed among two fructose
6-phosphate and one glyceraldehyde 3
phosphates so here's the fructose
6-phosphate here's the glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate that's the overall
stoichiometry of the pathway
so now what I'm going to do is go
through the chemical details of the
pathway down here at the bottom and on
the next page we've got glucose going to
glucose 6-phosphate and I draw three
lines there because I'll say this
glucose 6-phosphate is the abbreviation
that I use for the structure that's
shown right here so this is glucose
6-phosphate with the proper
stereochemistry now the hydroxyl group
on the glucose we we don't really know
it's what it's it's stereochemistry is
but we've got it up or in beta in in in
this drawing the first step is for the
the enzyme glucose 6-phosphate
dehydrogenase g6pd h2 attack the one
carbon the electrons go down to make a
keto functionality we lose hydride from
the one carbon which is used then to
reduce NADP to NADPH so that's our first
oxidation step I want you to notice that
this is a one-way arrow typically at the
top of a pathway and in this case it's
at the very top these are the steps that
are thermodynamically irreversible these
are also the steps where you principally
affect regulation of the pathway and as
I said earlier we're going to be running
three molecules of glucose 6-phosphate
through this this step the next molecule
in the in the pathway is this one this
is a lactone electone is a cyclic ester
so this is an ester and you can see it's
cyclic the next step involves the
addition of water bile actin A's in
order to open up this six membered ring
to give you this linear structure that
we'll see here and this is basically six
phospho glucuronic acid the next step
will involve the oxidation of the one
two three carbon I always try to find
places in any pathway where we've seen
the same chemistry before but with
different molecules
this step right here specifically
working with Latin A's in the enzyme
glucose 6-phosphate dehydrogenase I'd
like you to look back at the
tricarboxylic acid cycle specifically at
the enzyme isocitrate dehydrogenase
while some of the specifics are
different basically what you'll see is
the overall concept is the same for
what's happening in the next couple of
steps so let me now get back to this to
the drawing so what we have here is the
1 2 3 carbon is vulnerable to what's
going to be an oxidation event so a base
will remove the hydrogen from the 3
hydroxyl group the electrons that we're
holding the hydrogen to the oxygen will
now move down to the to the position
between the oxygen and the 3 carbon and
then the hydride on the 3 carbon will be
transferred to NADP to make NADPH so
this is the second of two oxidation
steps that gives us this ring open
structure here and just as happens in
the isocitrate dehydrogenase step what
we've done is we've generated a beta
keto acid whenever you see a beta keto
acid you really always want to think
that that's prone to either enzymatic or
spontaneous decarboxylation what you can
see is the enzyme the electrons can go
like this and like this and like this
and that will result in the cleavage of
the bond connecting carbon 1 and carbon
2 so now the new carbon 1 will be the
carbonate what was carbon 2 which is the
carbon that has this little purple ball
on it and we're going to lose the
terminal or 1 carbon as co2 this is the
in the co2 will have the triangle which
up until this point has defined our one
carbon now I just want to mention a
couple of things you know one is that
we'll look at I put on like there's a
dark ball here's a purple ball and
here's a black triangle these could be
for example experimentally you could use
a radioactive chemical
a radioactive atom in order to help you
trace the the the reaction as you go
from precursor to product I'm using
these just to help you see the
relationship of a precursor and a
product and what we see here is that the
one carbon is lost from the beta keto
acid as co2 and according to the kind of
chemistry that we've seen many times for
a decarboxylation now this is going to
give us a five carbon product over we
have lost the co2 and that is ribulose
5-phosphate and for this I'm going to go
on to the next page
on the previous page we saw the loss of
co2 from the one carbon of the beta keto
acid and this gives us this linear
structure five carbon ribulose
5-phosphate i've drawn it this way so
you can see what it didn't from the
perspective of what was a five carbon
molecule that has lost a six carbon
molecule that's lost one carbon but the
more formal chemical way to draw this
would be as the linear chain of five
carbons
starting with on the with the new one
carbon which is the the alcohol with a
purple circle the next carbon would have
a the carbonyl group which I'll use a
blue box and all the way down to the
what was the five carbon it would has
what is now the five carbon what was
originally the six carbon which has the
dark black dot now because we're
processing three molecules of hexose and
now pentose where we've got three
molecules of ribulose 5-phosphate and
the two enzymes that are going to
process this ribulose 5-phosphate
isomerase and ribulose 5-phosphate
ephemeris now just because of the
relative activities of these enzymes
we're going to see that about 1/3 of the
molecules will be processed by the
isomerase and 2/3 will be processed by
the apimage
now let me tell you a little bit about
what my summarization is and versus a
pin relation Bogdan and others have told
you about the importance of een dial or
dial eight intermediates in biochemistry
the section of the molecule in the
ribulose 5-phosphate that i'm circling
here if you just take and form an een
dial eight here what you can do is you
can move the carbonyl functionality from
the two carbon up to the one carbon and
what that's what happens when you form
go to convert ribulose 5-phosphate into
ribose 5-phosphate so it's a simple een
dial conversion very similarly I
could have made the eating dial between
the 2 and the 3 carbon and if I did that
I form a neend aisle and depending on
how I put the hydrogen back on that I'd
take off I can change the
stereochemistry at the 3 carbon in other
words I can form the epimer at the 3
carbon so I can go from this epimer on
the top to where the hydroxyl group is
pointed to the right to this epimer on
the bottom where the hydroxyl group is
pointed to the left this molecule the
epimer of ribulose 5-phosphate where the
hydroxyl on 3 is pointed to the left is
called xylose 5 phosphate as I said the
this enzyme this apimage enzyme is a
little more active than the iess than
the isomerize enzyme so we get about 2
molecules of the xylose 5 phosphate for
every molecule that we process again by
eand aisle 8 type intermediates to form
the ribose 5-phosphate so this gives us
our ribulose 5-phosphate is now
converted into one molecule of ribose
5-phosphate and two molecules of xylose
5 phosphate
I'm going to give you a little bit of a
mechanistic interlude here to remind you
of some of that some of the chemistry
I'm going to be showing you with the
enzyme trans key delays is very
reminiscent of chemistry we have seen
several times in 507 specifically the
the enzymes pyruvate dehydrogenase
pyruvate decarboxylase and alpha
ketoglutarate dehydrogenase now the
molecule that I have right here in this
little mechanistic interlude box is the
one of the ones we were just talking
about specifically this is xylose five
phosphate you see the epimer with the
three hydroxyl off on the left this
carbonyl group is exactly that the type
of carbonyl that's attackable by
thiamine pyrophosphate TPP we remind you
a little bit about why TPP can be a
nucleophile to attack this carbonyl
group TPP that when you look at the
whole cofactor it has attached up here
an amino pyridine and the amino group
can be in the amino tautomer and that
amino telomere can help pull off this
hydrogen lowering the PK so the PK of
this is actually something in the order
of eighteen or nineteen which is
sufficient to make this carbon a good
nucleophile to be able to attack the
carbonyl that's on our in this case
xylose five phosphate that attack will
result in the formation of an initial
addict in which the vitamin the TPP is
covalently associated with the xylose
five phosphate you can see the keto
group has been converted into a hydroxyl
group so we've now got a die hydroxy
molecule at this point and just as we've
seen with the other enzymes I've
mentioned earlier for example the
pyruvate dehydrogenase that the
delocalization of electrons through the
system makes it possible to be able to
remove this hydrogen these electrons
move to this position these electrons
move up here and that means that the
bond connecting the bottom three carbons
of the xylose five phosphate is broken
that gives you if you look at the
chemistry glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate the
very common biochemical intermediate and
what's left over is the vitamin teach PP
attached to two carbon unit and it's
called dihydroxy ethyl TPP hydroxy
hydroxy this is an ethyl group and it's
an anion though the TPP anion so i
abbreviate that - and then with a box C
- TPP it's a chemically reactive
nucleophilic intermediate that we're
going to be able to use to do powerful
chemistry
the enzyme trans key delays which I'm
going to talk about from the standpoint
of medical importance somewhat later
enables the removal of the top two
carbons by the chemistry I just showed
you it's a kind of a chemical
decapitation to remove the c2 TPP in
order to liberate it to be able to be
used as a chemical reagent so one of our
molecule both of our molecules of silos
five phosphate are going to be
susceptible to this chemistry and that
means we're going to get two molecules
of the C to TPP anion one here and one
here and two molecules of glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate here and here okay what are
we going to do with the C 2 TPP well I
want to draw your attention back up here
to the ribulose 5-phosphate remember I
told you that it's possible by way of an
end dialate intermediate with this
isomerize enzyme to move the carbonyl
group from the 2 carbon up to the 1
carbon and that produces ribose
5-phosphate one of the things that I
just want to point out here is ribose
5-phosphate was one of the things that's
that one of the goals of the pathway so
I could for example stop the pathway
here and shut off this ribose
5-phosphate to be able to make
nucleotides but this carbonyl is exactly
the kind of functional group that the C
to TPP looks for for chemical reaction
so I can plug in just like a Lego the C
to TPP on the 5 carbon ribose
5-phosphate what that does this gives me
5 plus 2 is 7
Sedo hep chiloe 7 phosphate 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 so you do have trilha 7 phosphate and
just because of the way the the
chemistry works with basically pushed
out the hydroxyl group of this position
off on the left and on the number 3
carbon okay so now we have a seven
carbon molecule and this is again this
is another biosynthetic opportunity as I
said
earlier ribose 5-phosphate can go off to
make ribonucleotides if you look up the
pathway of synthesis of the aromatic
amino acid tyrosine what you'll see is
that basically this is a you know the
biosynthetic intermediate that will go
off to produce that aromatic amino acid
okay so this is cito have jello seven
phosphate
now if I look at the top three carbons
here you've got basically an alcohol a
carbonyl and an alcohol this looks
almost identical to the carbon one two
and three that you see in the in the
aldolase reaction back in glycolysis in
other words the linear form of in that
case it's fructose 1 6 bisphosphate
forms when in the linear form looks very
much like this and what that means is
that the aldolase enzyme with the amino
group at its active site can attack this
carbonyl group to form in protonated
amine that will in the process of the
chemistry you can break the bond that
connects carbon 3 to carbon for this
molecule so the enzyme trans aldolase
that does this chemistry is very similar
to the aldolase enzyme that we have
looked at in the glycolysis pathway this
is the splitting in this case of a seven
carbon compound into a three carbon and
a four carbon whereas in the case of
glycolysis it was splitting a six carbon
compound into two three carbon compounds
this intermediate that I'm encircling
here with the amine is what's very
similar to the dihydroxyacetone
phosphate precursor so I'll call it a
DHA like fragment two ethyl ethanol to
methanol groups with a methyl amine in
the middle so what we've done is now
we've we've I've taken the top three
carbons of the CDO hep duo seven
phosphate and made it into something
that looks a lot like carbons one two
and three from the aldol a step of the
glycolysis pathway so it's a
dihydroxyacetone like phosphate i'm just
going to put that off to the side for a
minute the bottom four carbons carbons
four five six and seven of the c2 f07
phosphate are something we haven't
actually seen in 507 before but if you
look at what the what the structure is
it's going to be in
aldehyde one two three four carbon
aldehyde and this is a rich rose four
phosphate v4p now that in itself is not
a valuable molecule but it turns out
that we can make it into a valuable
molecule very easily remember back when
we were talking about this see to TPP
electrophilic molecule that can put two
carbons on to anything that has an
aldehyde at the end well with Rose four
phosphate has an aldehyde at the end if
we do the chemistry and we plug this C
two fragment onto the erythrocyte
fragment up at the aldehyde you get a
six carbon compound that is fructose
6-phosphate so this is the source of
fructose 6-phosphate that can then
become part of the gluconeogenesis or
glycolysis pathways so we haven't wasted
anything we've taken a kind of a trash
molecule erythrose four phosphate that
we don't have a lot of other uses for
and we've converted into something that
we can use for energy production just as
an example now what I'd like to do is
come back up to this dihydroxyacetone
like fragment that I talked about a
little bit ago in the glycolysis pathway
we start with the hexose glucose and
eventually after about four or five
steps we get to another hexose fructose
1 6 bisphosphate then the aldolase step
takes and splits that in half into on
the one hand a dihydroxyacetone like
fragment and in the other hand a
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate fragment and
the dihydroxyacetone like fragment is
covalently connected by way of its
middle carbon the carbonyl to the enzyme
aldolase when we look at what's
happening in the trans aldolase reaction
is really the same thing we've taken the
seven carbon molecule in this case and
we've split off this three carbon
intermediate again it's chemically just
about identical to what happened
in glycolysis when we pulled apart the
six carbon sugar and we've now got this
thing on
right which we can do something with the
dihydroxyacetone phosphate is covalently
connected to the enzyme trans aldolase
it's a trans aldolase it can do the
aldolase reaction the splitting but then
it can take and it can transfer very
easily what are we going to transfer it
to well the dihydroxyacetone phosphate
chemically can be transferred very
easily to a glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
so I'm going to find a way now to find
to connect this dihydroxyacetone like
fragment to a glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
and i find one right here let me go back
a little bit and see where it came from
I had the xylose 5 phosphate I knocked
off the top to come up the carbons I
used those in order to make the seed
ohef GL o 7 phosphate my residue was the
3 carbon molecule glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate and again this could be a
waste product but instead of using it as
a waste product
what I can do is to take the
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate that is a
waste product of the the trans key
delays reaction down here and I can
utilize it by combination with the
dihydroxyacetone phosphate from up here
the transiently aldolase reaction trans
aldolase has the transfer ability to
bring these molecules together
covalently plug them together 3 & 3 to
make 6 that's your second molecule of
fructose 6-phosphate
while I've still got the this the sheet
with the whole pathway on it I'm going
to give you a little bit of a summary I
took three molecules of glucose
6-phosphate oxidized it twice generated
two molecules for each molecule of
glucose 6-phosphate i got two molecules
of NADPH the reducing equivalents the
pathway up to that point created a beta
keto acid therefore there was this
decarboxylation event so I ended up with
is three five carbon molecules ribulose
5-phosphate the ribulose 5-phosphate
depending upon the balance of activities
the next two enzymes will partition at
about a two to one ratio into xylose
five phosphate and ribose 5-phosphate
then I explained how the ziolo 5
phosphate had this carbonyl at the
second position and that looked like the
carbonyl and a lot of other biochemical
reactions we have seen earlier in 507
it's vulnerable to attack by the illud
carbon ion of TPP thiamine pyrophosphate
applying that trans key delays enzyme to
xylose 5 phosphate split off the top 2
carbons as this electrophilic chemical
reagent that I call c2 TPP the bottom 3
carbons became glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate the C to TPP got added on to
ribose 5-phosphate which is one of the
molecules that was made from early on
ribulose 5-phosphate that made the seven
carbon molecule seto Hep C lo 7
phosphate and again I said that that's a
precursor to other things like aromatic
amino acids if you need them the seto
Hep C lo7 phosphate however has a
structure that makes it amenable to
having its top 3 carbons taken off by an
aldolase like enzyme trans aldolase what
makes this aldol a special is it will
take the 3 carbons off as a protein 3
carbon addict
and allow that three carbons to be added
on to one of the glyceraldehyde 3
phosphates that was generated in the
Transkei delays reaction 3 plus 3 is 6
and that becomes your fructose
6-phosphate overall what happens is you
you put in 3 glucose 6-phosphate you
lose some co2 s and you produce 2
fructose 6-phosphate and one leftover
glyceraldehyde 3 phosphates 3 phosphate
and these are in the main stream of
glycolysis and gluconeogenesis so that's
the details of the pathway we start with
the 6 carbon compound 3 molecules of it
and we generate 3 molecules of co2 we're
going to generate 6 molecules of NADPH
and the at the beginning of the page
that we're looking at here we have 3
molecules of a 5 carbon compound this
ribulose 5-phosphate and again in this
at this point the carbon scrambling
phase takes over and at the end we end
up with taking the the 15 carbons of the
three five carbon ribulose 5-phosphate
s-- and scrambling them into 2 6 carbon
fructose 6-phosphate
and 1 3 carbon glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate
we've now looked at the pentose
phosphate pathway from two levels let's
say initially what I see right here is
the pathway from the let's say the
10,000 foot level we see there's the
mainstream of metabolism of glucose to
pyruvate
that's glycolysis or pyruvate to glucose
gluconeogenesis and we have seen how in
the pentose phosphate pathway we go from
glucose 6-phosphate we do some oxidation
that's why how you get the NADPH you
lose some co2 you get the pentoses I've
I have introduced you to ribose ribulose
and cellulose then in order to get these
pentoses back into mainstream metabolism
we do this complicated carbon scrambling
routine and then get back to fructose
6-phosphate & gap to be able to continue
in mainstream metabolism nothing is
wasted
there's the 10,000 foot level and then I
went down here at the bottom to sort of
the 2 foot level all of the little
details of the chemistry so I've taught
you this that the the pentose phosphate
pathway at the in the beginning at the
10,000 foot level and then got you down
to the 2 foot level with all of the
details of the chemical mechanisms and
our course biological chemistry 507 is a
chemistry course so that's very
appropriate but 507 is also 2507 20 is
the biological engineering department
and the engineers actually think a lot
about let's say mathematical equations
more than chemical equations and they
think about schematics written out like
you'd look at an electrical schematic so
because by ok biological chemistry group
we have is quite large we have kind of
an ending to this pathway that appeals I
think to the to the the to the more the
engineering mindset so for the engineer
so I'm going to move from the two-foot
level up to the about the 100 foot level
and I'm going to present it as a
schematic the shorthand that I use
involves these little boxes each of
these is a molecule
and the abbreviation is in the top g6p
glucose-6-phosphate it has six carbons
that'll help me keep track of how many
carbons are there and there are three
molecules of it so we've got 6 times 3
or 18 carbons that we start with in the
oxidative phase we've seen that we each
molecule gives rise to two NADPH --is
2 times 3 is 6 ok so we've got 6 NADPH s
there are 3 molecules that are starting
and remember that that beta keto acid
that's formed we have three of those and
they're going to decarboxylate so I get
rid of 3 Co 2's so that is the broken
line indicates the boundary between the
reversible I'm sorry the irreversible
and the reversible parts of the reaction
this gives us ribulose 5-phosphate
that's our initial product entering the
pathway just 5 carbon molecule there are
3 molecules of it total of 15 carbons
depending upon the activities of the pin
raise on the bottom e or the isomerize I
on the top you get a just you either get
more or less of the x5p xylose 5
phosphate or ribose 5-phosphate R 5 P
and as I said typically the the chem
arrays wins out by about 2 to 1 over the
isomerase so we've got a simple
isomerization to take the ribulose
5-phosphate to ribose 5-phosphate the c5
molecule you get one of those so we've
got five of our carbons over here if we
look at the apimage reactions we get two
boxes one each one for each molecule of
xylose 5 phosphate each of them are c5
one so there are two molecules now let's
take our first molecule of xylose 5
phosphate the one in the top x5p box and
again we keep in mind that these these
arrowheads going both ways because the
carbon can flow both ways in these
reactions these are equilibrium reaction
we can take the top off of two carbons
off of the x5p
this is the time in pyrophosphate
reaction and what that does is it gives
us that that chemically reactive C to
TPP fragment carbon to two carbons one
of those okay and the bottom half is
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate a three
carbon molecule one of those the ribose
5-phosphate the 5 carbon aldehyde can
have the C to pc2 TPP add to its one
carbon two carbons plus five carbons
give 7c to Heptulla seven phosphate is
the product one molecule of those trans
aldolase can split off the top three
carbons to make that die hydro acetone
like fragment this is the one that's
covalently attached by this amine like
bond to the triose sugar 3 carbon sugar
one molecule of that and after you do
this trans aldolase reaction and you've
taken off the top 3 carbons you've got a
residue of 4 carbon so that's the
erythrocyte c 4p CSE for one molecule
now the trans aldolase reaction can do a
transfer so it will take this DHA that I
hydroxy acetone like fragment and
combine it with glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate that it got from the
molecule one of xylose 5 phosphate so we
can follow the schematic silos 5
phosphate gives us this gap molecule
gristle aldehyde 3 phosphate it can
combine with the molecule the DHA plus
DHA like fragment to form for our first
molecule of fructose 6-phosphate
which will then go off into glycolysis
and gluconeogenesis
now the residue of this was this erythro
spor phosphate product what can we do
with it so again this is an owl this is
an aldehyde it can react with a c2
fragment from the c2 PPP so TPP so where
we
that situ PPP is from our second
molecule of a ellos 5 phosphate trans
key delays takes off the top 2 carbons
and plunks it on to the Rif throws four
phosphate to form our second molecule of
two of fructose 6-phosphate
c6 one molecule and what's left over
after all is said and done is this
fragment right here glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate
c3 molecule one molecule so if I did
this correctly we should have 15 carbons
over here 6 6 & 3 and we do so these are
the molecules that will flow into
glycolysis and gluconeogenesis now
because most of these arrows are
double-headed you can also imagine that
fructose 6 phosphate and glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate in the mainstream metabolism
in glycolysis and gluconeogenesis can
backflow right to left and end up with
these pentoses so for example if i
wanted to make ribose 5-phosphate in
order to make ATP and i didn't need any
reducing equivalents all I would do is
run all of this in Reverse get up to
this point ribose 5-phosphate and then
take this off to make nucleotides on the
other hand if I'd like to make just nad
pH for biosynthesis what I would do is
the following
I'd start with my glucose 6-phosphate
early on yield my six NADPH s go from
right from left to right across the
pathway all the way to produce fructose
6 phosphate and gap and then what I do
is I'd use gluconeogenesis in order to
convert fructose 6 phosphate and gap
back into glucose 6 phosphate that then
would be able to re-enter the pathway
once again now what I want to do is go
to show you that I want to go back to
the original a drawing that I had to
show you how that would work so what I
just said was that if I if I were in a
situation
where all I wanted was NADPH I could do
the following I could enter the carbon
from glucose 6-phosphate make the
pentoses get my NADPH and then take the
carbon and flush it back through the
pentas scrambling phase to produce
fructose 6-phosphate and gab
now here's the important part is I can
now through gluconeogenesis move the
carbon back up to glucose 6-phosphate
and do it again and again and again
in other words recursively I can
metabolize all of the carbon from
glucose 6-phosphate all six carbons can
eventually become converted into co2
with copious amounts of NADPH and that's
part of the power of this pathway it's
very versatile you can use it to make
reducing equivalents you could use it to
make sugars you can use it to make c2
hep Jalloh 7 phosphate to make aromatic
amino acids it's a very powerful pathway
the top part of this this picture shows
us the schematic in the pathway and I
think with the schematic up there I
think it's this is a good time to make
some summary comments so one thing I
mentioned the very beginning is that we
need NADPH in order to finance
biosynthesis of lipids in particular for
making membranes so these are needed for
growth so I think now you can see why
this pathway is very is turned on in
cells that are making new tissue that
are making new cells if you run it in
the oxidative mode that's the one that I
just described where you purely use it
to make NADPH you can oxidize all the
carbons of your your glucose 6-phosphate
into co2 that's the scenario that I just
ran
I didn't emphasize enough that if you
for example you you eat food that
contains nucleic acid which of course we
all do that nucleic acid contains ribose
that ribose we want to be able to do
something with and what happens is it
enters right here into the pathway in
other words I want to take that ribose
and if I wanted to make energy out of it
the ribose would go from left to right
and I would end up with fructose
6-phosphate glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
that I could use that putting it through
glycolysis and then the TCA cycle to
make energy
point four is one
I mentioned earlier I'm a toxicologist
and point four shows how NADPH helps us
defend against oxidative stress and I
have this little cartoon at the bottom
free radicals are a consequence of you
know of living in an aerobic environment
we breathe oxygen it can be incompletely
reduced to produce things like super
oxide and hydrogen peroxide and even
hydroxyl radical these are chemically
very dangerous and they'll form
peroxides and other molecules that can
cause disease so we have protective
systems based on a variety of small
molecules in the cell one of them is
called glutathione millimolar
concentrations of glutathione exist in
our liver cells and they exist in order
to be able to do the kind of chemistry
I'm going to show you right here so a
peroxide that I'm pointing to ROH is
dangerous because it can give rise to
these free radicals that can be damaging
to us we can do is take two molecules of
this sulphur containing glutathione it's
a tripeptide and they will give up their
H there hydrides in order to be able to
basically break this roo H into ROH and
alcohol and HOH water in other words
relatively harmless products now
glutathione the rsh sometimes called gsh
sacrifices itself and becomes this
oxidized form our SS are now the
reaction that does this first parts
called glutathione peroxidase in order
to restore our cellular stores of
reduced glutathione rsh we have to take
the oxidized form our SS are and we have
to reduce it that's where the NADPH
comes in NADPH is the cofactor used by
glutathione
reductase and what it does is puts in
the reducing equivalents to basically
convert oxidized glutathione back to the
what we want which is the reduced
glutathione that then can then go on to
protect us against free radicals NADPH
has a very special role in protecting
any cell from oxidative stress it has a
very special role however when you deal
with red blood cells red blood cells
lack a nucleus they lack a mitochondrion
they pretty much entirely cytosol
cytosol has a glycolysis pathway that's
where they get their energy and the
pentose phosphate pathway which is where
they get the reducing equivalents that
are necessary to help maintain the red
blood cells integrity if you think about
it you know our red blood cells carrying
a lot of oxygen oxygen itself can be
very damaging red blood cells are
damaged and you really need to have
these reducing equivalents available in
order to maintain the the structural and
functional integrity of a red blood cell
so anything that disrupts the NADPH pool
in a red blood cell ultimately causes a
kind of anemia because that means the
red blood cell can't persist as long as
it would otherwise people who have
defects in NADPH metabolism for example
a person who might have a defect or a
sluggish first enzyme in the pathway the
pathway the the glucose 6-phosphate
dehydrogenase the red blood cells
because of this NADPH realm don't last
as long clinically it's observed that
these people have somewhat of a
resistance against diseases such as
malaria that might be because the red
blood cells don't last long enough for
the organism that causes malaria
Plasmodium falciparum to be able to
complete its life cycle so sometimes a
genetic defect can actually provide an
asset and that some places in the world
where people have evolved in the in the
presence of the malaria Plasmodium
organism they have defects in the plathe
way they're maintained from generation
to generation in order to be resistant
to the environment the six point I want
to bring up with regard to
this pathway has to do with the the
enzyme at the top of the pathway once
again that the glucose 6-phosphate
dehydrogenase I mentioned in the very
beginning but I want to reiterate that
enzymes that are at the top of a pathway
where there is thermodynamically
reversible steps they are places where
you have the ability to control entry
into the pathway so these are the rate
determining steps and in this case the
presence of nad plus that is the product
determines the the rate of passage
through the the pathway so for example
if a cell has been doing a lot of
biosynthesis the nadp+ levels go up that
has a it interacts allosteric li in
order to be able to increase the
throughput of the pathway so you
increase the amount of NADPH
biosynthesis to be able to let it match
the the biosynthetic needs associated
with doing a lot of lipid biosynthesis
so this is the regulated step
the last thing I'm going to say about
the the pentose phosphate pathway is
that it's strikingly similar to the
pathway called the Calvin cycle which
are the dark reactions of photosynthesis
photosynthesis involves the capture of
one co2 into a five carbon scaffold and
to make a six carbon compound then that
six carbon compound splits into three
carbon compounds it turns out if you if
you work with enough molecules of five
carbon compound what you're able to do
is go through the carbon scrambling
phase and work all your way back to the
hexose glucose the carbon scrambling
intermediates are almost identical
chemically to the ones that we've just
looked at in the pentose phosphate
pathway so if you look at they're at the
calvin cycle you will see three carbon
and four carbon and five carbon and six
carbon and even seven carbon
intermediates identical so that nature
again didn't reinvent the wheel twice
what it did was at some point in time it
took the pentose phosphate pathway and
it converted it into the photosynthetic
dark reactions or perhaps vice versa
they have different purposes the
photosynthetic pathway involves
capturing carbon in order to make
hexoses that we can use to store for for
energy and future energy use or to make
hexoses you could use to make cellulose
if you're a plant and the other hand a
pentose phosphate pathway again the same
chemistry but in this case the chemistry
is all aimed at taking the hexose the
the the six carbon compound and using it
to make reducing equivalents that we can
use for biosynthesis or to protect us
from oxidative stress or to make ribose
is that we need when we're growing in
order to be able to make nucleic acids
nucleotides ATP and so on that we need
the pentose phosphate pathway may seem a
little bit difficult to learn but it I
think it's very worthwhile it is
something that provides us with through
with amazing versatility it gives us
compounds that are chemically reactive
that at the level of two carbons three
carbons four carbons five carbons six
carbons and seven carbons you can take
these pieces and you can make a wide
array of molecules that are absolutely
essential for life moreover it provides
us with reducing equivalents which we
need to grow biosynthesis moreover those
reducing equivalents also help protect
us from oxidative stress that helps keep
us alive and healthy longer so the
pentose phosphate pathway is complicated
because it does so many different things
but any one of those things I think in
itself makes it worthwhile learning all
of this complicated chemistry so that's
the pentose phosphate pathway from the
10,000 foot level down to the 2 foot
level incredibly versatile pathway and I
hope that this has helped you understand
it thank you very much